all right luckily joe biden is set to
hold that official first press
conference on thursday be a lot of
practice this week so maybe he'll have
some answers for us
about the border crisis and i'd like to
know if joe really feels he was blown
over by the wind on friday but don't
hold your breath
joe is likely going to spend the next
several days memorizing prepared lines
is to have his little note cards with
him
there are no public events over the
weekend no public events today
and while his schedule has yet to be
released don't expect to see much of joe
until thursday
this is practice week he's apparently
spending every waking moment preparing
for the presser
here with more former trump white house
press secretary kelly mcinerney now
i don't know that when when donald trump
held the rally
the press would would scream and yell
this this is a super spreader event
okay we just saw griff jenkins and i
didn't see much social distancing
in tijuana mexico where migrants are
waiting for their moment to cross and
i think kaylee i'm just guessing that if
you ever said that donald trump tripped
while boarding air force one um
because the wind blew him over i don't
know
if you would have kept your job after
that
yeah i don't think so we all remember
ramp gate
and that of course was the slippery ramp
at west point where it was merely kind
of a hydroplane moment that ended up
being a week-long news cycle
and just the true explanation was
something entirely unacceptable to the
press and they ran wild with his
uh suggestions of neurological issues i
mean it's incredible what the bynum
white house is able to get away with and
that's why i am hopeful thursday
uh we'll see but the press needs to ask
these really hard questions of him
and i'm not just saying you know what
are your thoughts on the border that's
not
a sufficient checking of the box
question they need to ask him
you say you blame this on trump explain
to me specifically how this is trump's
fault
when in fact numbers came down when he
took historic immigration action in 2019
and they've gone up and they're wearing
biden t-shirts flying biden flags and on
camera
citing that they're coming here because
of you they need he needs to be
confronted that directly
and that specifically all right and i'd
like to know if
it's his official position if he got
blown over by the wind
because it's ridiculous and now we have
vladimir putin
mocking him and we have let's see we
watched what happened in anchorage
alaska last week where china spent 20
minutes lecturing
us about human rights abuses uh and
there wasn't any pushback but believe it
or not an apology maybe we could ask
those questions
just a thought absolutely yes absolutely
and he also
should be asked you heard peter ducey
say and i saw this moment today
uh they would not confirm whether he saw
a doctor after or not
he should be asked that question i'll
never forget being asked from the podium
about president trump and
going back to his trip to walter reed
from a year ago and
questions about whether he had had a
mini stroke which was preposterous
nothing of the sword had happened but
they were taking that kind of a deep
dive
into his medical history with all these
conspiracy theories so yes they need to
ask that
the disastrous confrontation with china
you're right where it was bewildering to
watch our secretary of state
apologize for america to a human rights
abuser that is committing genocide
against an entire people group and that
of course is china with the uyghurs but
we apologize
uh for america she can't cross the table
from china
when the president gave the speech at
west point it was a ramp
it was raining the president had dress
shoes on there's no other time that i
can think back to
in his presidency where he walks slowly
uh if i have dress shoes and it's slush
and it's ice and it's snow you get that
whoa i got the wrong shoes on today and
you go slowly
it was one time and he didn't fall down
three times because he was smart enough
to go a little slower kaylee thank you
that's exactly right
thank you